This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“percent”，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台上搜索。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个深谙此道的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这样去做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑简直炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，在这里我们探讨
some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is. for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another day, back for another topic. Today, we have a very special episode dedicated to dating with intention and finding meaningful
我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，迎来新的一天，探讨新的话题。今天，我们有一集非常特别的节目，专门探讨如何在二十多岁时带着明确的目的去约会，并建立有意义的
connections in our 20s. Being single in our 20s can sometimes. feel like an uphill battle or a bit of a minefield. Everywhere we look, there is someone who comes with baggage or the commitment phobe or they're emotionally unavailable or just not the right fit. And I've noticed that it can cause us to become quite cynical and kind of shy away from meeting new people or dating at all. But many of us in this decade are still seeking companionship and more than that, we're seeking partnership. And with that, comes a more mature approach to dating and dating with intention.
联系。在二十多岁时保持单身，有时感觉像是一场上坡战，或者有点像雷区。无论我们看哪里，总会有人带着沉重的包袱、对承诺感到恐惧、情感上不可得，或者只是不合适。我注意到这会导致我们变得相当愤世嫉俗，甚至有点抗拒结识新朋友或根本不想约会。但我们这一代人中的许多人仍然在寻求陪伴，不仅如此，我们还在寻求伙伴关系。随之而来的，是一种更加成熟的约会方式，也就是带着目的去约会。
Dating with intention doesn't mean that every person you go on a date with has to be the one or that you need to be expecting an engagement ring within the first 12 months. It's more so that you've done the inner work and the inner healing to identify the people and the romantic connections that are going to serve you and make you a better person. and maybe that could lead to something bigger. It's an approach that I've adopted recently, and in the past I've been really candid with you all before about my very fun and tumultuous dating history,
带着目的去约会并不意味着你约会的每一个人都必须是你的真命天子，也不意味着你需要在前12个月内期待一枚订婚戒指。更多的是指你已经做了内心的功课和内心的疗愈，以识别那些能够成就你、让你成为更好的人的人和浪漫关系，也许这能促成更重大的事情。这是我最近采用的一种方法，过去我曾向大家非常坦诚地分享过我那有趣而又动荡的约会历史，
from flings to year-long situationships to engaging with people, I knew weren't good for me, and quite honestly, it got to the stage that I just didn't have the energy to do that anymore. It was fun for a while, but I value my time and my emotional and mental well-being too much now to kind of entertain these kinds of relationships. So today I want to share with you how we can date with intention in our 20s.
从露水情缘到长达一年的“友谊以上恋人未满”，再到与那些我知道对我不利的人交往，说实话，到了某个阶段，我真的没有精力再去那样做了。有一段时间这确实很有趣，但我现在太珍视自己的时间和情感与精神健康了，不再愿意去维持这种类型的关系。所以今天我想和大家分享，我们在二十多岁时如何做到带着目的去约会。
Psychology has a lot to say about this topic, as always, and it recognizes that our 20s are at this very pivotal stage in our personal and relational development. A lot of the research that we encounter in this area emphasizes the importance of self-awareness and establishing clear goals and values when entering the dating world. And it also articulates that by understanding ourselves and our desires, we are better able to navigate relationships with greater purpose and authenticity. Studies have also suggested that I would say in a generation and a moment, modern day that is characterized by a very fast-paced, very digital approach to dating using
心理学对这个话题有很多见解，一如既往，它承认我们的二十多岁是我们个人和关系发展的关键阶段。我们在这一领域接触到的大多数研究都强调了自我意识的重要性，以及在进入约会世界时建立清晰目标和价值观的重要性。它还明确指出，通过了解自己和我们的欲望，我们能更好地以更高的目标感和真实性来驾驭人际关系。研究还表明，我想说在一个以快节奏、非常数字化的约会方式为特征的当代社会，使用
apps like hinge and Tinder, making the conscious decision to date with intention can contribute to longer-term relationship satisfaction and personal growth. It encourages us, us in our 20s, to really cultivate emotional intelligence and a willingness to engage in self-reflection and to step beyond our comfort zone. Overall, all of the concepts, all of the articles, all of the research that I've come across demonstrates the value of approaching dating in your 20s with intention because this is what lays the groundwork for healthy relationship patterns
像Hinge和Tinder这样的应用程序，做出有意识的决定去带着目的约会，可以促进长期的关系满意度和个人成长。它鼓励我们这些二十多岁的人真正培养情商，以及进行自我反思并走出舒适区的意愿。总的来说，我遇到的所有概念、所有的文章、所有的研究都证明了在二十多岁时带着目的约会是非常有价值的，因为这为健康的交往模式
and of course personal fulfillment in the future. So today we're going to talk about it from the very practical ways that you can develop your own. own self-awareness and self-discipline to identify and know what's right for you. We're going to talk about understanding the motivations and intentions of others, meeting people organically, and maintaining your authenticity. I'm here for all of it. Without further ado, let's dive into how we can date with intention and form meaningful connections in our 20s. Dating is fun. It's meant to be fun. And in our 20s, it can be particularly exciting.
以及未来的个人成就奠定了基础。所以今天我们将从非常实际的方法来谈论它，教你如何培养自己的自我意识和自律能力，以识别并了解什么才适合你。我们将讨论理解他人的动机和意图、自然地结识他人以及保持真实的自我。我非常期待这一切。废话不多说，让我们深入探讨如何在二十多岁时带着目的约会并建立有意义的联系。约会是快乐的。它本来就应该是快乐的。而在我们的二十多岁，它可能尤其令人兴奋。
There's all these fish in the sea, as they say, so many options. But sometimes it can also be a challenging experience. I say it all the time, but this decade is a profound period of self-discovery, exploration, and often a time when we seek companionship and genuine connection. However, it's important to approach dating with intention, understanding our own desires and goals and being mindful of the qualities that we seek in a partner. The truth is that our romantic relationships have a profound impact on our identity, our lives, our self-concept, and psychology acknowledges that our sense of self is shaped through interactions
正如他们所说，海里的鱼多得是，有很多选择。但有时它也可能是一次具有挑战性的体验。我经常说，这个十年是自我发现、探索的深刻时期，通常也是我们寻求陪伴和真诚联系的时期。然而，带着目的去约会是很重要的，要了解我们自己的欲望和目标，并注意我们在伴侣身上寻找的品质。事实是，我们的浪漫关系对我们的身份、生活、自我概念有着深远的影响，心理学承认我们的自我意识是通过与他人的互动塑造出来的，
with others, and romantic partnerships play a significant role in this process, the emotional intimacy and the support offered can foster feelings of acceptance and belonging, which are of course crucial for a positive self-concept. But when you're in the wrong relationship, when you're wasting your time with someone who doesn't actually care about you or doesn't fill your cup up who doesn't fulfill you, it's also going to carry potential for negative impacts. Difficulties or conflicts within a relationship can lead to self-revellinger. doubt, they can lead to insecurity, and a distorted sense of self. There's also the fact that any
而恋爱关系在这个过程中扮演着重要的角色，所提供的情感亲密和支持可以培养接纳感和归属感，这对于积极的自我概念当然是至关重要的。但是，当你身处错误的关系中，当你把时间浪费在一个根本不真正在乎你、无法滋养你、无法让你感到充实的人身上时，它也会带来潜在的负面影响。关系中的困难或冲突会导致自我怀疑、
relationship, but particularly ones with a romantic partner, are going to take up a large amount of time. And time is precious at any age, really, but especially in this era of our lives, when we really have all of these opportunities to go out and make mistakes, to explore the world, you don't want to feel tied down or held back by someone that you've chosen to be with. Essentially, that means that we want to make sure we're not investing in a relationship that is taking away from our identity and may inevitably just leave us drained and heartbroken. Sometimes that's unavoidable. Things don't work out for a myriad of reasons. But I think if you're like me, I've reached a point in my 20s, if not my life in general,
不安全感以及扭曲的自我认知。还有一个事实是，任何关系，尤其是与浪漫伴侣的关系，都会占用大量的时间。在任何年龄，时间都是宝贵的，但在我们生命的这个阶段尤其如此，当我们真的拥有所有这些机会去外出犯错、去探索世界时，你不会想被你选择在一起的人束缚住或拖后腿。本质上，这意味着我们要确保自己没有投资于一段会削弱我们身份、最终可能只会让我们精疲力竭和心碎的关系。有时这是不可避免的。事情因为各种原因而无法成真。但我认为如果你像我一样，我在二十多岁时已经达到了一个阶段，如果不是我整个人生的话，
whereby I've learnt the lessons that I needed to. I've done it. I've had the breakup experience. I've forced connections that weren't there. And I'm kind of done with the casual dating life. I do think there's a time and a place for that. You learn a lot about yourself. You learn what you like.
我已经吸取了我所需要的教训。我已经经历过了。我经历过分手的痛苦。我曾勉强维系那些并不存在的联系。我已经有点厌倦那种随意的约会生活了。我确实认为那是需要时间和地点的。你会对自已有很多了解。你会知道自己喜欢什么。
But I now realize that dating is a time commitment and it takes away energy from the other things that I care about and what I want to be invested in. And with that has come a commitment to dating with intention. And that doesn't mean that I'm giving up on the occasional casual date or even hookup, but it's about being able to recognize that chemistry is not the same as compatibility and setting up healthy boundaries around what you expect from a partner and identifying when someone is bringing that to the table.
但我现在意识到，约会是一项时间投资，它会分走我关心的其他事情以及我想投入精力的能量。随之而来的是对带着目的约会的承诺。这并不代表我放弃了偶尔的随意约会甚至是一夜情，而是能够认识到化学反应不等同于契合度，并围绕你对伴侣的期望建立健康的界限，同时识别出某人是否真正带来了这些。
So what does it mean to date with intention? Well, it involves being intentional about our actions and our choices when it comes to our romantic connections. It means taking the time to reflect on our own needs, our own desires and long-term goals before entering into a relationship with our eyes closed. When we date with intention, we are more likely to attract partners, who align with our values and share our aspirations. It's all around, I think, a better deal for everyone involved. It respects the other person and not wasting their time. But it also shows that you respect yourself because you're not going to entertain something that may actually do more harm than good. So how can we implement this? There are four critical pillars that are the foundation for dating,
那么，带着目的约会意味着什么呢？嗯，这意味着在我们的浪漫关系中，我们的行动和选择都要有明确的目的。这意味着在闭着眼睛进入一段关系之前，花时间反思我们自己的需求、我们的欲望和长期目标。当我们带着目的约会时，我们更有可能吸引到那些与我们的价值观一致、拥有共同志向的伴侣。总的来说，我认为这对参与的每个人来说都是更好的选择。它尊重对方，不浪费对方的时间。但这同时也表明你尊重自己，因为你不会去经营一段实际上可能弊大于利的关系。那么我们该如何实施这一点呢？有四个关键支柱是约会的基石，
with intention. The first one is understanding your own values and your own goals. Secondly, setting healthy boundaries, a secret ingredient to all relationships, not just romantic. The third is being open to surprises and organic connections. And finally, maintaining realistic expectations and not getting anxious or desperate if it maybe takes you some time. I, always say this so I'm sorry if I sound like a broken record, but I would much rather be single until I'm in my late 30s or 40s, then settle with someone that I'm not sure about at 25 and find myself heartbroken 10 years later. I think it's about reminding ourselves that good things take time. So let's start with how psychology can inform our values and goals around pursuing a
那就是带着目的。第一个是了解你自己的价值观和目标。其次是设定健康的界限，这是所有关系的秘诀，而不仅仅是浪漫关系。第三是对惊喜和自然建立的联系保持开放的态度。最后是保持现实的期望，如果可能需要一些时间，不要感到焦虑或绝望。我总是这样说，所以如果我听起来像个复读机，我很抱歉，但我宁愿单身到三十多岁或四十多岁，也不愿在25岁时和一个我并不确信的人将就，然后在10年后发现自己心碎。我认为这关乎提醒我们自己，好事多磨。所以让我们从心理学如何指导我们追求浪漫关系的价值观和目标开始。
romantic connection. There is, of course, a lot of science, a lot of psychology that plays a crucial role in understanding our motivations and our behaviors in the dating realm. Research suggests that having clarity about our own values and goals is key to finding meaningful connections. In this study that was published in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, research has found that individuals who engage in self-reflection and have a clear understanding of their values and life goals tend to make more intentional dating choices. And this makes a lot of sense, right? You need to know yourself before you're going to attempt to really know someone else. And we can implement this in a lot of ways. We can
当然，有大量的科学、大量的心理学在理解我们在约会领域的动机和行为方面发挥着至关重要的作用。研究表明，对我们自己的价值观和目标有清晰的认识是找到有意义联系的关键。在这项发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》上的研究中，研究人员发现，那些进行自我反思并对自己的价值观和生活目标有清晰理解的个人，往往会做出更有目的性的约会选择。这很有道理，对吧？在你试图真正了解别人之前，你需要先了解自己。我们可以通过很多方式来落实这一点。我们可以
implement this understanding in a way that is going to make our dating life more fruitful. Here are a few exercises that I personally did when I was thinking about intentional dating, kind of testing the waters. The first one is around value assessment and clarification. How can we know that someone is right for us if we don't even know what we want or what we stand for? So value clarification helps us put a label on this, helps us identify what these values, what these core principles that we hold, really are. So I want you to sit down. I want you to go to Google right now and find a list of the 100 most common values. These will be things like kindness, like learning, curiosity, optimism, loyalty, family, creativity, etc., etc. And from those, I want you to pick 20 that most resonate with you.
以一种让我们的约会生活更有成果的方式来理解和落实这一点。这里有一些练习，是我个人在考虑有目的的约会、试水时做过的。第一个是关于价值观的评估和澄清。如果我们甚至不知道自己想要什么或我们的立场是什么，我们怎么能知道某人是否适合我们呢？因此，价值观澄清有助于我们为这些东西贴上标签，帮助我们识别这些价值观、我们坚守的核心原则到底是什么。所以我希望你坐下来。我希望你现在就去谷歌上找一张包含100个最常见价值观的列表。这些将是善良、学习、好奇心、乐观、忠诚、家庭、创造力等之类的事情。从这些当中，我希望你挑出20个最能引起你共鸣的。
Then from that list, choose your top 10 and then finally your top 5. For me, these are creative. independence, leadership, community and generosity. These things are what define me and they are what contribute to my outlook on life, my personality, my identity, all of the good things. You need to align your dating behaviours with the values that you select. If you go on a first date with someone who doesn't value humour or generosity and you do, it's not going to work. And of course, you don't need to be completely on the same page because opposites attract and sometimes people can bring very individual parts in themselves to the table.
然后从那个列表中选出前10个，最后选出前5个。对我来说，这些是创造力、独立性、领导力、社区和慷慨。这些事情定义了我，它们造就了我的生活观、我的性格、我的身份，所有美好的事物。你需要将你的约会行为与你选择的价值观保持一致。如果你和某个人进行第一次约会，而他不重视幽默或慷慨，而你重视，那是行不通的。当然，你不需要完全步调一致，因为异性相吸，有时人们会把他们身上非常独特的个人特质带到桌面上来。
But what level of compromise are you willing to accept? And is that a big enough compromise that it's going to hurt you in the future? I'll give you an example here about someone I dated for around three months last year. Lovely guy, nothing but the best. but I remember on one of our early dates, he was talking about how his ideal weekend is to literally not leave the house and just rest the entire time. That is not me. I like to be out and about. I like to be adventurous and I'm curious. That's something that I value. And by knowing this about myself, I knew pretty quickly, well, three months in, so obviously not that quickly, but I knew that it
但是你愿意接受什么程度的妥协呢？这是否是一个足够大的妥协，以至于将来会伤害到你呢？我在这里举个例子，关于我去年约会了大约三个月的某个人。很可爱的小伙子，无可挑剔，但我记得在我们早期的几次约会上，他谈到他理想的周末是 literalmente 甚至不离开家，整整两天都在休息。那不是我。我喜欢到处走走。我喜欢冒险，而且我充满好奇心。那是我所珍视的。通过了解自己这一点，我很快就知道，好吧，是在三个月后，所以显然没那么快，但我知道这
wasn't going to work out and that any more time I spent with this person would kind of be a waste. And yes, they gave me some amazing learning experiences, but that wasn't really what I was looking for. The second element of this is understanding your own goals and desires when it comes to dating. And I want you to be brutally honest with yourself here. If you are a massive monogamous, stop trying to force yourself into month-long flings or situationships because you're trying to be with someone you're not meant to be with or you're trying to make them happy. If you know that you are someone who wants commitment, which I assume you are
是行不通的，我花在这个人身上的任何更多时间都将是一种浪费。是的，他们给了我一些很棒的学习经验，但那真的不是我在寻找的。这第二个要素是了解你在约会时的目标和欲望。我希望你在这里对自己残酷地诚实。如果你是一个坚定的一夫一妻制主义者，不要试图强迫自己去进行长达一个月的露水情缘或友谊以上恋人未满的关系，因为你试图和一个本不属于你的人在一起，或者你试图让他们开心。如果你知道自己是一个想要承诺的人——我假设你是，
since you're listening to a podcast on dating with intention, then have that conversation early on. And if someone says that's not what they're looking for, believe them. Don't try and change their mind. Don't try and change yourself to fit their requirements. move on. There's this super common saying at the moment that if they wanted to, they would, but I saw someone the other day say something even better. If they don't want to, someone will. Practice an abundance mindset when it comes to dating. There are millions of potential partners in the world, and when you understand your own values and intentions, that means that when the right person comes along, you'll know and you won't need to compromise.
既然你在听一个关于有目的约会的播客——那就早点把这件事沟通清楚。如果有人说这不是他们想要的，请相信他们。不要试图改变他们的想法。不要试图改变自己去迎合他们的要求。继续前进。现在有一句超级流行的话，如果他们想的话，他们就会去做，但我前几天看到有人说了一句更好听的话。如果他们不想，别人会去做的。在约会时保持丰盛的心态。世界上有数百万潜在的伴侣，当你了解自己的价值观和意图时，这意味着当对的人出现时，你就会知道，而你不需要妥协。
Another important aspect of intentional dating, the second pillar, if you will, is setting healthy boundaries. This means understanding and communicating your own limits and expectations when it comes to a relationship. This research that was published, I think a couple of years ago, it suggested that setting and maintaining boundaries is associated with healthy relationships and increased relationship, satisfaction. There's a quote I love, and that is that the most compassionate people have the strongest boundaries. And boundaries help us to define what is acceptable and what is not. They foster a healthy dynamic that is built on mutual respect and understanding. And it stops someone from
有目的约会的另一个重要方面，即第二个支柱，是设定健康的界限。这意味着在恋爱关系中理解并传达你自己的底线和期望。这项几年前发表的研究表明，设定并维护界限与健康的关系以及更高的关系满意度息息相关。我有一句很喜欢的名言，那就是最有同情心的人拥有最强的界限。界限帮助我们定义什么是可接受的，什么是不接受的。它们培养了一种建立在相互尊重和理解之上的健康动态。它能防止别人
crossing a boundary that maybe you haven't even articulated. It stops resentment. It stops you feeling uncomfortable and it allows you to have more fruitful dates, have a more fruitful dating life, more fruitful relationships in general. It comes down to communication. Whether you're single right now or in a relationship, the best connections are established on spoken and unspoken boundaries. Be clear with the people on your roster or who you are dating that there are certain things you are after and certain things that you expect. And it's their decision whether to live up to those or not. But you know what you deserve and make sure that they know that as well and reciprocate
跨越一个你甚至还没有明确表达的界限。它能防止怨恨。它能防止你感到不舒服，并让你拥有更有成果的约会，更有成果的约会生活，以及普遍更有成果的人际关系。这归根结底取决于沟通。无论你现在是单身还是在恋爱中，最好的关系都是建立在说出口的和没说出口的界限之上的。向你名单上的人或你正在约会的人明确表示，有些事情是你所追求的，有些事情是你所期望的。至于他们是否能达到这些标准，那是他们的决定。但你知道你应得的是什么，并确保他们也知道这一点，并对他们报以同样的理解。
that understanding for them. What do they want? What do they need? That will allow you to see whether you are the right fit. I know this sounds really clinical and maybe strange to bring up almost like a job interview, which we never want. But it doesn't have to be like that. You can make this known on your dating profile or after a few dates.
他们想要什么？他们需要什么？这将让你看出你们是否真正契合。我知道这听起来很冷门，甚至有点奇怪，几乎就像一场求职面试，这是我们永远不希望看到的。但它不必是那样的。你可以在你的约会资料上或者在几次约会之后让对方知道这一点。
Just make them aware that you're looking for a relationship by subtly saying something like I'm not a huge fan of casual dating or just straight up tell them. Bite the metaphorical bullet. If anything, like I said before, it's actually super compassionate because you're not wasting any more of each other's time if it turns out that you're not on the same page. And that is okay. boundaries keep us safe and they allow us to feel respected and know when someone doesn't respect us. If you have certain guidelines or expectations in a relationship, if you want to spend four nights a week
只需让他们知道你在寻找一段关系，可以通过委婉地说一句类似“我不太喜欢随意的约会”这样的话，或者直接告诉他们。咬咬牙面对现实。如果非要说的话，正如我之前所说，这其实是非常富有同情心的，因为如果事实证明你们不在同一个频道上，你就不会再浪费彼此更多的时间了。那也是可以接受的。界限保护我们的安全，让我们感到被尊重，并且知道什么时候别人不尊重我们。如果你在关系中有某些准则或期望，如果你想一周花四个晚上
with someone or if you don't like it when they text other people who are the same gender as you or if you are expecting a little gift every now and again, the easiest way for that to be fulfilled is to just tell them. It comes down just to that. So something so simple, just communicate what you're after. But a question I get a lot is how do we find those meaningful connections amidst the sea of potential partners? I think we often confuse dating with intention to dating in abundance and treating it like a job where your objective is to find the one. I've had friends who treat it this way. They go on five dates a week and they're almost screening people.
和某人在一起，或者如果你不喜欢他们给和你同性别的人发短信，或者如果你偶尔期待一个小礼物，实现这一切最简单的方法就是直接告诉他们。归根结底就是这样。如此简单的一件事，只需沟通你所追求的是什么。但我经常遇到的一个问题是，在潜在伴侣的海洋中，我们如何找到那些有意义的联系？我认为我们经常把带着目的约会混同于海王式的广泛撒网，并把它当作一份工作，你的目标是找到真命天子。我有过这样对待约会的朋友。他们一周约会五次，几乎像是在筛选
for compatibility. And the existence of dating apps makes that a lot easier. But I think what we're looking for when we talk about dating with intention is quality over quantity. And that brings me to my next major tip, which is to let life surprise you and be open to an organic connection because you are genuinely never going to know what someone is like or if you have that compatibility until you actually meet them. And if you've already met, then that kind of makes it even better. You know, there's nothing worse than your friend who swears off dating apps and tells you that they only meet people organically and that anyone who doesn't is too lazy or they're
兼容性。而约会软件的存在让这一点变得容易得多。但我认为我们在谈论带目的约会时所寻找的是质大于量。这就引出了我的下一个重大建议，那就是让生活给你带来惊喜，对有机的联系保持开放的态度，因为在真正见面之前，你永远不会真正了解一个人是什么样的，或者你们是否有这种契合度。如果你已经认识了，那这种感觉其实更好。你知道，没有什么比你的朋友对约会软件发誓说他们只通过自然途径结识人更糟糕的了，他们还告诉你任何不这样做的人都太懒了或者他们
missing out. But I think I'm going to be that annoying friend today. I'm so sorry, dating apps, they are convenient and they are fun, but you also never know who you're going to click with based on five photos and a quote about how they love Seinfeld or pineapple on pizza. And if you've done that before and you're done with the lack of authenticity that is inherent in dating apps, here are some tips on how to foster organic romantic connections. There has been tons of research that suggests that engaging in activities and communities that align with your interests and values can increase the likelihood of meeting like-minded individuals, not just people that you might consider dating.
错过了。但我今天要扮演那个讨人厌的朋友了。我很抱歉，约会软件确实很方便也很有趣，但根据五张照片以及一句关于他们多么喜欢《宋飞正传》或披萨上的菠萝的名言，你也永远不知道自己会和谁擦出火花。如果你以前做过这种事，并且已经受够了约会软件中固有的缺乏真实感，这里有一些关于如何培养自然浪漫联系的建议。有很多研究表明，参与符合你兴趣和价值观的活动和社群可以增加遇到志同道合的个体的可能性，而不仅仅是那些你可能考虑约会的人。
Joining clubs, attending events, or pursuing hobbies, particularly those that are group-based, not only, I think, enriches our lives, but also creates opportunities for genuine connections to form beyond the realm of the dating apps. Studies in social psychology have also shown that similarity, plays a significant role in attraction and relationship satisfaction. When we share similar values and interests with our partner,
加入俱乐部，参加活动，或追求爱好，尤其是那些以群体为基础的爱好，不仅能丰富我们的生活，还能在约会软件的领域之外创造建立真诚联系的机会。社会心理学研究还表明，相似性在吸引力和关系满意度中发挥着重要作用。当我们与伴侣分享相似的价值观和兴趣时，
it fosters a sense of understanding and mutual support. So being open to discovering shared interests with a potential partner or romantic interest can be a great starting point for building a meaningful connection and maybe also a relationship. Part of that includes stepping out of your comfort zone. Our comfort zone is this psychological state where we feel safe and secure. It feels easy and convenient, but not much growth really happens there. My mom, she has a saying that you can either feel comfortable or you can grow.
它会培养一种理解感和相互支持感。因此，对与潜在伴侣或浪漫兴趣发现共同兴趣保持开放态度，可以成为建立有意义联系乃至关系的绝佳起点。其中一部分包括走出你的舒适区。我们的舒适区是一种心理状态，在这个状态下我们感到安全和有保障。它感觉轻松且方便，但并没有真正的成长发生在那里。我妈妈有一句名言，你要么感到舒适，要么你就能成长。
And of course, at the moment we're talking about dating, but it really applies to everything. Stepping out of your comfort zone and accomplishing something new, trying something new, it really boosts our self-confidence and that attracts amazing people when we're confident in ourselves when we believe in ourselves and our capacity to handle challenges when we're excited about life all of that confidence spills over into other areas of our lives positively impacting our relationships our personal well-being and also how we come across to other people If your goal is to date intentionally and all of your past relationships have been duds, maybe it's worth doing something differently and seizing some new opportunities.
当然，我们现在谈论的是约会，但这实际上适用于所有事情。走出舒适区并完成一些新事物，尝试一些新事物，确实能极大地提升我们的自信心，而当我们对自我充满自信、当我们相信自己以及我们应对挑战的能力、当我们对生活充满热情时，这种自信就会溢出到我们生活的其他领域，积极影响我们的关系、个人福祉，以及我们在其他人面前的形象。如果你的目标是有目的地约会，而你过去所有的关系都很糟糕，也许值得做点不同的事情并抓住一些新的机会。
Go to some art openings. Say yes to that party where you don't know anyone. Go on the blind date. What's the worst thing that can happen? Honestly, what's the worst thing that can happen? You have a bad date? It doesn't work out? Well, you've been through that before.
去看一些艺术展开幕式。对那个你谁都不认识的派对说“好”。去相亲吧。最坏的情况会发生什么？老实说，最坏的情况会发生什么？你经历了一次糟糕的约会？事情没有成功？好吧，你以前经历过那种事，
and I always say that it just makes for better stories and isn't that what our 20s are about, creating memories even if they're terrible or embarrassing or awkward to look back on. It's also about adopting a what if mentality. In psychology, the what if mentality, it's kind of seen as a negative thing and it refers to this kind of cognitive tendency to always think the worst case scenario is going to happen. So individuals with a strong what-if mentality, they often ruminate on various scenarios and they dwell on uncertainties. But I like to think about it differently and kind of flip this narrative to one that is positive and optimistic. What if it all works out?
我总是说这只会带来更好的故事，难道这不正是我们二十多岁意义所在吗？创造回忆，即使它们回头看起来很糟糕、很尴尬或很别扭。这也是关于采用一种“如果……会怎样”的心态。在心理学中，“如果……会怎样”的心态在某种程度上被视为一件消极的事情，它指的是那种总是认为最坏情况会发生的认知倾向。因此，拥有强烈“如果……会怎样”心态的个人，常常会对各种情境进行反刍，并纠结于不确定性。但我喜欢以不同的方式思考，把这种叙事翻转成积极和乐观的一面。如果一切都顺利呢？
What if you meet an amazing new person? What if you have the best time? That's what dating with intention is all about. letting yourself be surprised and actually having fun with it. When we begin to put pressure on ourselves and think that dating with intention means that we'll find the love of our life straight away, I think we're only going to be disappointed. So that's what we're going to talk about in just a second.
如果你遇到了一个非常棒的新人呢？如果你度过了最美好的时光呢？这就是带目的约会的全部意义所在。让自己感到惊喜，并真正从中获得乐趣。当我们开始给自己施加压力，认为带目的约会意味着我们会立刻找到一生的挚爱时，我想我们只会感到失望。这就是我们接下来要讨论的内容。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以摒弃那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on. on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即“2%”。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me,
我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，
not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在白天谈论快克，但是，是的，是的，字面意思。但为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们现在桌上还摆着艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们
are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different
已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的
intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你只是真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们共同探讨关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于 paternity 丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This, this. is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑简直炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这，这。就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，
as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
因为劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这还没结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
We naturally put a lot of pressure on ourselves when it comes to finding someone, especially in our 20s. We can find ourselves constantly being bombarded with images and reels and pictures and stories about true love and soulmates, and we feel bad that we don't have that, and that it's because there's something wrong with us. Not only is that not true, but it can also interrupt our journey and our pursuit of intentional dating. When we get stressed, we begin to compromise on our values and our intentions and we can become desperate. And I don't really like that word, but it's probably the best way to explain how we react when
当谈到寻找某人时，我们自然会给自己施加很大的压力，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候。我们发现自己不断地被关于真爱和灵魂伴侣的图像、短视频、图片和故事狂轰滥炸，我们为自己没有这些而感到难过，并且觉得这是因为我们自身有什么问题。这不仅不是真的，而且它还会打断我们的旅程和对有目的约会的追求。当我们感到压力时，我们开始对我们的价值观和意图妥协，我们会变得绝望。我其实不太喜欢这个词，但这可能是解释当事情没有按计划真正进行、事情没有我们想象的那么容易时我们的反应的最好词汇。
things aren't really going according to plan and when things aren't coming as easily as we thought they would. So lastly, it's essential to be patient and maintain realistic expectations. While dating can sometimes feel like a bit of an uphill battle or a roller coaster ride, it's important to remember that building a meaningful connection takes time. Research published in the Journal of Positive Psychology, my favorite, I love positive psychology. It suggests that having realistic expectations and taking baby steps in a relationship and during the initial months of dating contributes to long-term relationship, relationship satisfaction. That can be hard. Baby steps are hard. And I'm saying that from
所以最后，保持耐心和现实的期望是至关重要的。虽然约会有时感觉像是一场上坡战或过山车，但重要的是要记住，建立有意义的联系需要时间。发表在《积极心理学杂志》上的研究——我的最爱，我爱积极心理学——表明，在关系中以及约会初期保持现实的期望并采取小步骤，有助于长期的关系满意度。这可能很难。小步骤很难。我是从
personal experience. Often we can get really carried away with the warm and fuzzy feelings and being admired or liked by someone that we forget to use that logical part of our brain and reflect on whether we want the same things, whether this is going in a direction that we would like it to. in those moments, let's go back to the very beginning. What are our values? What are we not willing to compromise on? And what is our goal here? If you're at the same stage as I am,
个人经验出发这样说的。通常，我们会被那种温馨模糊的感觉以及被某人欣赏或喜欢冲昏头脑，以至于我们忘记使用我们大脑中逻辑的那部分，去反思我们是否想要同样的事情，这是否正朝着我们希望的方向发展。在那些时刻，让我们回到最初。我们的价值观是什么？我们不愿意在哪些事情上妥协？我们这里的目标是什么？如果你和我处于同一阶段，
I cannot do another four-month relationship and look back and realize that all the red flags were actually there from like the third date. I just chose to ignore them because I was getting desperate and I got carried away. I think it's really important to be clear, on those things before you even begin to start going on dates in an intentional way. I want you to take 10 minutes and write out a list that you can come back to when you feel like
我无法再经历一段四个月的关系，回头才发现所有的红旗其实从第三次约会左右就已经在那里了。我只是选择忽略它们，因为我变得绝望并且被冲昏了头脑。我认为在开始以有目的的方式去约会之前，先把这些事情搞清楚真的很重要。我希望你花10分钟写下一张清单，当你感觉
settling or selling yourself short. Kind of like a non-negotiables list. I have my own list, I will say, and they kind of read almost like affirmations. Some of them are things like I'm looking for someone who respects me. I am looking for someone I can grow. with I am not looking for a casual relationship. I am not willing to compromise on the exclusivity of my relationship after three months have passed. Your past self and your logical self is going to be a lot more wise than your smitten self because when you are getting feelings for someone, all of that dopamine, all of that oxytocin, all of that serotonin is flooding your brain and interrupting the rational part of you that should be focused on those intentions that you've set from the beginning.
委曲求全或贬低自己。有点像一份不容妥协的清单。我必须承认，我自己也有一份这样的清单，而且它们读起来几乎就像是自我肯定。其中一些是这样的：我在寻找一个尊重我的人。我在寻找一个能与我共同成长的人。我不想要随意的恋爱关系。在三个月过去之后，我绝不会在关系的排他性上妥协。你过去的自己和理性的自己，会比那个陷入热恋、神魂颠倒的自己明智得多。因为当你对某人生出好感时，你大脑中会涌入大量的多巴胺、催产素和血清素，从而干扰了你理智的那一部分，而这部分本该专注于你从一开始就设定好的那些意图。
You also need to show yourself some self-compassion as well. It's okay if you've been on like a hundred shitty dates or if you've been ghosted or no one's wanting to commit or it just doesn't seem to be working out. The right person is going to come because you're fucking amazing. You're a catch. And I know it gets said all the time, but anyone would be lucky to have you. If you're going to date intentionally, don't forget your self-worth. And when you find yourself engaging in kind of that negative spiral or self-pity, thinking it will never happen for you and what happens if it doesn't, I think it's worth reminding ourselves that it is much better to be alone
你也需要向自己展现出一些自我同情。如果你经历了一百次糟糕的约会，或者被无故失联（ghosting），又或者没有人愿意承诺，亦或事情似乎总是不顺，这都没关系。对的人终究会出现，因为你真的超级棒。你是个极具吸引力的人。我知道这话老生常谈，但谁能拥有你都是他们的幸运。如果你打算带着明确的目的去约会，千万不要忘记你的自我价值。当你发现自己陷入那种消极的漩涡或自我怜悯中，觉得这种事永远不会降临到自己头上，或者万一真的没有呢，我觉得我们很有必要提醒自己：单身总比
than in a relationship that doesn't elevate you. So it's important to be realistic, take the time to get to know someone, embrace the journey, lower your expectations, and just enjoy the process. When we have low expectations for something, although it's really hard to do that, especially if you're someone who's very much a romantic like me, but those expectations are always going to be exceeded, right? Low expectations means greater happiness when the good thing does arrive. I want to pause here and make a quick disclaimer about a misconception I see all the time about intentional dating. Taking this approach doesn't mean that all of your relationships from now
处于一段无法提升你的关系中要好得多。因此，保持现实、花时间去了解一个人、拥抱这段旅程、降低期望并享受这个过程，这些都非常重要。当我们对某事抱有较低的期望时——尽管这真的很难做到，特别是如果你像我一样是个极度浪漫的人——但这些期望总是会被超越的，对吧？较低的期望意味着当美好的事物真正到来时，会有更大的幸福感。我想在这里暂停一下，对一个我经常看到的关于“带着目的去约会”的误解做一个简短的说明。采取这种方法并不意味着你从今以后
on have to be pointed towards marriage or towards the idea of forever, or that you have to be 110% sure you want to marry this person before you even go on a first date with them. you can still have your one-night stands if you want, you can kiss a few frogs, but at the end of the day, I think this approach is all about reminding yourself what you're after and having enough respect for your own well-being and your own ambitions and intentions to not compromise on your values and to not waste your time. It might seem callous to say that dating or casual dating is a waste of time, but it kind of is. I always think about it. in the sense that we out, you know, 24 hours that we have in the day, that needs to be divided up
所有的恋爱关系都必须指向婚姻或“永远在一起”的概念，也不意味着你在和某人进行第一次约会之前，就必须百分之百确定自己想嫁给他或娶她。如果你愿意，你仍然可以有一夜情，可以去亲吻几只青蛙（经历几次错误的选择）。但归根结底，我认为这种方法的全部意义在于提醒自己你究竟在追求什么，并且对自己的幸福、雄心和意图有足够的尊重，不为自己的价值观妥协，也不浪费自己的时间。说约会或随意的约会是在浪费时间，听起来可能有些冷酷，但某种程度上确实如此。我总是这样思考：
over so many different activities. It has to be divided into work, into hobbies, into family, into just looking after yourself, friendships, and then there's room for love. And if we invest in the wrong person, we're going to have to compromise on those other things and we're not going to get the benefits from doing that. I would much rather spend time with my friends at the moment than spend time with someone who doesn't really listen when I talk or who is just kind of using me. That just, I haven't, I have too much self-respect for myself at this point in my life to entertain that anymore.
在我们一天拥有的24小时里，这些时间需要被分配到许多不同的活动中去。它必须被分配到工作、爱好、家庭、照顾自己、友情之中，然后才留有给爱情的空间。如果我们把时间投资在错误的人身上，我们就不得不在其他事情上做出妥协，并且无法从中获得益处。比起把时间花在一个当我说话时并不怎么认真听，或者只是在某种程度上利用我的人身上，我现在更愿意和朋友们在一起。我只是……在人生的这个阶段，我对自己的自尊有着足够高的要求，不再去搭理那种行径了。
And yes, it's come from a lot of past experiences that have been hurtful, but I'm so grateful for that maturity that I now have. I know it's not for everyone. and I know there are heaps of other alternatives and approaches and I applaud them and maybe you did meet your partner from a one-night stand or from a dating app. That's incredible. But for me, that hasn't really worked out so far. Maybe in the future it will.
是的，这种心态来自于过去许多令人伤痛的经历，但我非常感激自己现在拥有这种成熟。我知道这种方法并不适合所有人，我也知道还有成堆的其他替代方案和方法，我对它们表示赞赏。也许你确实是通过一夜情或交友软件遇到了你的伴侣，那真是太棒了。但对我而言，这种方式到目前为止并没有真正奏效。也许在未来会吧。
But for now, I do want to be more conscientious with the people I led into my life, particularly in a romantic context. So that's where I stand. Little rant concluded. let's do a quick summary of what we talked about today. Today, of course, we discussed the concept of dating with intention and finding meaningful connections in our 20s. We explored those four main pillars of intentional dating, those being understanding your values,
但就目前而言，我确实希望在让我进入我生活的那些人身上更加谨言慎行，特别是在浪漫的语境下。这就是我的立场。小小的吐槽到此结束。让我们快速总结一下我们今天讨论的内容。今天，我们当然讨论了带着目的去约会（intentional dating）的概念，以及在我们二十多岁时寻找有意义的连接。我们探讨了带着目的去约会的四大支柱，即理解你的价值观、
setting boundaries, allowing yourself the opportunity to meet people organically, and lowering your expectations and being realistic. We also talked about how it's kind of a journey of self-discovery and how we can stop ourselves from settling and choosing the wrong people. I know that our 20s are sold to us as this time of a lot of freedom and exploration, but you can still do that within the confines of an intentional and safe space for yourself. Romance is a big part of our lives, but we don't want it to overrule all the other amazing good things that we have going on. So I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I really enjoyed it. This has been something on my mind for a long time.
设定界限、让自己有机会自然地结识他人，以及降低期望、保持现实。我们还讨论了这如何在某种程度上是一段自我发现的旅程，以及我们如何阻止自己将就和选择错误的人。我知道，二十多岁常常被推销为充满自由和探索的时期，但你仍然可以在一个对自己而言有目的且安全的空间里做到这一点。浪漫是我们生活中很大的一部分，但我们不希望它压倒我们正在进行的所有其他精彩美好的事物。所以我真的希望你喜欢这期节目。我真的很享受。这件事已经在我脑海里盘旋很久了。
And I kind of felt like a little bit of a loser explaining this to my friends and being like, yeah, I'm done with casual sex. I'm done with situationships. But they were all so supportive. And I was like, maybe we need to share this on. And I know it's kind of a common idea nowadays. But I am such a huge proponent. I hope you are too. If there is someone in your life who needs to hear this episode, you should share it with them.
而且当我对朋友们解释这些，说“是的，我受够了随意性行为，我受够了‘友达以上恋人未满’（situationship）”时，我感觉自己有点像个失败者。但他们都非常支持我。我想，也许我们需要把这些分享出去。我知道这在如今算是一个很普遍的观点，但我绝对是坚定的支持者。我希望你也是。如果你的生活中有人需要听听这期节目，你应该把它分享给他们。
It might be a little bit on the nose, but maybe they'll get a kick out of it. As always, if you enjoyed today's episode, if you enjoy the show, please feel free to leave me a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. Not only does it help me grow, but I read every single review. They really make my day. and I just want to thank you for all of the support and all of the kind words that you write and that you share. If you have an episode suggestion, if there's something going on in your life and you're looking for the psychological explanation, please follow me at That Psychology podcast on Instagram and send me a suggestion for an episode. I love reading them and sometimes I do them.
这可能会有点直白切中要害，但也许他们会从中获得一些启发。一如既往，如果你喜欢今天的节目，如果你喜欢这个栏目，请随时在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方给我留下五星好评。这不仅能帮助我成长，而且我每一条评论都会读。它们真的能让我开心一整天。我只想感谢大家一直以来的支持以及你们所写下的所有暖心话语并进行分享。如果你有节目建议，如果你的生活中发生了什么事，并且你正在寻找心理学解释，请在Instagram上关注我：That Psychology podcast，并给我发送节目建议。我很喜欢阅读它们，有时我也会把它们做成节目。
So you never know. I hope you have a lovely day wherever you are and we will be back. next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange
所以你永远不知道会发生什么。希望无论你在哪里都能拥有美好的一天，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养精神韧性、
modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
健身以及建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的走出困境的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO percent，可在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看往昔》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for both.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于双方来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
black people. Listen to look back at it on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor.
黑人。在I Heart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看往昔》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难中学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。在AHA广播应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难中学习》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格蕾丝，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的大脑直接炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河的陷阱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人呈现。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。